Elia Kazan man yeah the best audition
he's ever seen really yeah yeah that's
right
how did he live I think Ilya was in his
eighties yeah yeah but sharpest attack
he got caught up in the McCarthy era in
fact yeah yeah yeah I think welcome
Holly welcome everybody to another
episode of hot boxing with Mike Tyson I
am Evan Britton and I am Mike Tyson Mike
yes I worry brother I'm pretty awesome
today Mickey Rourke
Mickey welcome ma'am thank you very much
really nice to be yeah I would see Mike
and you know quite a long time that's
awesome monocle together
I remember we get out of article
together drinking a magnum of champagne
with no shirts on yeah and we've also
got our brother Chuck Zito in the house
haven't you yo yo Mike Kevin great
thinking about yeah so did you get did
you convince Mickey to come in yeah
mining convinced my ass him you say to
go up through many awesome haven't seen
Mike in a while and that's great not
almost a great podcast and I haven't
seen Mike since we were in Monaco and
very funny story I think very few people
know about over here but Mike and I had
to present an award to someone write a
music award I don't want to say the
guy's name because I don't like to do
anyway we had to present an award to
somebody and they had the lines on a
monitor and Mike and I had to read the
lines off the monitor now earlier in the
day they gave us both the satellites and
we just like took off on his motorcycle
somewhere and disappeared all day so we
we went over the lines for like I think
10 seconds yeah there we get to the show
and we're doing the lines
all of a sudden I can't read the lines
my kid
save the lies and mike says is your line
I go no Mike that's your it was just
that a really great disaster what what
year was that I don't known each other
long time a long time yeah women and men
do poorly Herman yeah yeah Paulie yeah
back in the day cool back over 25 years
that's awesome
I remember I did a I was foolish enough
to say I'll do an exhibition against the
guy who was a former light heavyweight
champion and I never sparred with
headgear on why'd you do that Mick I
know I never well I never sparred with
headgear because Jerry quarry never
sparred with high gear who was like
somebody I always looked up to you know
because he was the only white fighter
that could fight you know and it was
like I never wore headgear so the night
that we did the afternoon that we did
the exhibition against the world
champion Tom estate Tom estate right
yeah Frank Frank Frank a free bill
Satan's pudding god rest her soul bill
Slaton is putting headgear I go bill I
can't wait I think he's good you gotta
wear it for this and I just got the piss
boxed out of me in it I could hear the
audience for you know three or four
rounds come on Mickey Mike Mike out
their route lay on you know like that's
awesome yeah yeah was it was it wasn't a
good day from here the guy wasn't taken
either of me no no no what happened was
he caught me with a good punch so I
faked like I was hurt and then he
stepped back and then I came over with a
right who and he gave me a he gave me a
school and after that ed Frank at the
time was a very great fighter you know
ya know tell me in history a very
underrated you know name that you don't
hear a lot oh yeah he could he could go
absolu
well I mean as prolific as you are as an
actor boxing is really your heart man
right you know what people when people
ask me that question it was what I
started out doing at 11:00 at the 5th
Street Gym in Miami and I had a lot of
great role models there you know with
Ollie and Jimmy Ellis and absolutely
Joe Dundee and they were Andrew yeah
Dundee didn't train me that wasn't that
good he I was an amateur there you know
Luis Rodriguez really Pastrana before
that and it all started for me when
Willy used to come to the boys club and
give us lessons when we were all amateur
fighters and and I really liked it you
know I liked it a lot and I really
wanted to play baseball but that didn't
work out is it the whole team thing
the boxing but the box and I can
honestly say because you know I come
from a very dark place and all the dudes
I grew up with around me and they ended
up in a darker place and the boxing
really gave me a discipline and a
something to let the steam out and they
and some to take away the shame yeah and
it you know kind of saved my life in a
in a very big way yeah you know I
totally get that now there's so much to
you know getting knocked down and being
able to get back up and pick yourself up
all the time some inner demons doing
those individual sports battling
yourself yeah you know with those demons
of doing yourself you know they never
died he's [ __ ] would you follow you all
the time yeah no doubt man I think
basically for me I don't I don't talk a
lot about it a lot is my mother married
a very brutal man that was not my father
and he did for a decade he did some he
did a lot of damage and so you you live
a shame and there's nothing there's
nothing worse than living with shame so
what you do is you make a decision
you're gonna break or you gotta get
strong yeah and then you're gonna after
you get strong you're gonna get hard
yeah
and then when I started with the acting
you know I had gotten so hard that I
didn't realize that it kind of offended
other people and my therapist explained
to me that that your pride pride and
your self-respect and your honor can
turn on you and become a weakness and so
you've got to be careful of that because
people then people get a you know afraid
of you right which is which which is
what was the whole point to begin with
you know yeah and then you got to
reinvent yourself and go okay I don't
need to do this I don't need to make eye
contact with every [ __ ] that
walks by I don't need to you know I got
I can just learn to live peacefully yeah
you know you said to me one day he said
you ain't going to war brother and you
got a lot of armor on you you know it's
like when I act it's it's on you know
it's it's I heard some actor one time
say it's not competitive well with me it
is yeah because I'm gonna grind you up
and turn you into dust
it's like be competitive because the
prize to be won it in there today yeah
you know it's like it's like the good
thing maybe when I went back to boxing
what I realized about acting
when that little red light goes on
that's like the bell ringing you ain't
get you can't say oh I got it wait give
me a second I gotta go no when that
bells on man you got it yeah you got to
be ready to go out and destroy you know
Mike I bet you can relate to that that
fear that ripped all right I'm so happy
to do anything in the redesign yourself
it was totally sizing the guy ever view
the big guy you live your life it is man
no doubt yeah but will you come from the
other dark side that's that's the way is
yeah you know yeah you're constantly in
that mode yeah that's fine and then it
then it becomes a it can backfire on you
you know in life later on yeah yeah
Bakken became dark for me yeah came to
the dark in what ways Mike I became a
self-absorbed yeah
really think about many people yeah
really weird having that ego that's why
I'm thinking about the toliet this
destroys all that yeah for sure man
that's what that's all about make you
have you heard of the toad medicine yeah
that would always show me in the other
room that blue stuff mmm no oh yeah
that's Devon yeah no the toad is it's
the Sonoran Desert toad and in its venom
they have this compound called five Meo
DMT have you ever heard of DMT no so DMT
is something that we create in our
pineal gland it's I like this it's
something that they say that the biggest
rush of it comes when a baby is forming
in the womb and then the second dose you
get of it in your life naturally is on
your deathbed and sometimes they say you
get a little sprinkling of it here and
there but you know ancient tribal
societies have used this medicine via
like ayahuasca to have spiritual
experiences they're finding now in
modern science that it cures everything
from addiction and depression to cancer
and a host of other illnesses and Mike
did five Meo DMT the other day with our
with this medicine man shaman and you
know he had a really incredible
experience I mean writing in at first is
so frightening I come from my experience
coming from
oh no I don't want this gnome I want to
stop naturally yeah what you called five
Meo DMT or DMT lasts long enough
it's about DMT if you do like an
ayahuasca ceremony that might be that's
like an 8 to 10 hour ride but this stuff
that Mike did it's only about 15 20
minutes you experience an ego death as
they call it incredible I got one of
those Tommy Hearns hit me with I got a
ego death eight hours after heavy they
had to take me to get MRI as I couldn't
dial the phone or I didn't even know my
name
oh he's [ __ ] man I'm sure and that was
an exhibition yeah yeah well how did you
guys all meet I mean you guys are
buddies how did how did you guys come
together we really think about coming
down to Paulie Paulie Herman Simon had a
cafe in New York City
yeah his thing was introducing people to
people oh yeah yeah that's so funny
his I remember when I first met Paulie
Herman I had an ice-cream cart and I
used to push it haha I used to push the
car from the East Village all the way up
to Central Park holy Sh and then there
was just kind of hip restaurant like all
the actors and famous people go yeah so
I would tie my ice cream cart up and I
would go like I'd stand out there
looking at famous people going Wow and
I'd say to Paulie could could I come in
yeah and he'd go well he'd say uh we're
a little crowded tonight maybe later and
I'd stand out there freezing and then in
the wintertime I had a pretzel cart so I
tied the pretzel cart up and I'd wait
and pause by then Paulie knew me a go on
go ahead go in you know and so you know
I go in there so after about seven eight
more years well I made it as a actor
right so I didn't have to wait line no
more you know I or tie my card up so I
go in there one night and I said I want
that table right there by the wind
Oh Paulie says no problem puts me in
there I'm sitting in there by myself
just looking for something and I guess
and I'm there about 45 minutes you know
having a something and Paulie comes over
to me he goes Mickey Mickey the Saudi
prince of so and so once your table
would you mind moving to the I said
listen you tell the Saudi prince to go
[ __ ] himself
there ain't no [ __ ] way he's getting
this table after me waiting 10 years to
sit here yeah paulie's gonna Mickey why
do you gotta be like that I know you
didn't push that cart like I did forty
two blocks every night that's awesome
Mickey used to uh pushed a good Yuma
cart the Good Humor cart that was next
to the Oh
the building was next to the Hells Angel
clubhouse in New York City oh yeah and
he used to push it all the way up to
Central Park right in front of the
Mayflower Hotel and said some of them
won't be in there and he wanted to be
getting the penthouse apartment there no
[ __ ] my back got real strong for pushing
that cart from third Street to third
Street yeah from third Street to 50 uh
what was it 59th Street or yeah 15
actually 60 Street yeah but his heart
was half empty too Tommy got because all
the Hells Angels they do really take
care of you they make fun of all the
other guys who sold ice cream because
they were all kind of like a quart short
you know huh we had inspection you had
the life stand up at attention in our
white uniforms I used to throw mine off
with the Hatton set put my tank top on
and a pair of jeans and I wouldn't wear
the uniform uniform so I never made good
humor man of the the month or whatever
gone need to have your picture on a wall
Yeah right that's so awesome
were you were you going to the Actors
Studio yet at that point yeah you were
yeah day and night Elia Kazan man
yeah the best auditions ever seen really
yeah yeah that's right
how did he live to be I think Ilya was
in his eighties yeah but sharpest attack
why he wasn't he um he got caught up in
the McCartney area back then yeah he did
yeah and I think I heard that name I saw
so many pictures about him and yeah
fights that I think he got blackballed
from Holly yeah he gave up some names
yeah but they put a lot of people there
were a lot of actors and directors had
suffered during that common this hunt
huh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's crazy man and then we had a
friend years ago called Jimmy Hayden
that uh was doing a play with Al Pacino
and he wound up VP played a yahoo what
was a maker junkie anyway right yeah and
he wound up dying from an overdose but
uh we will pallbearers me Mickey and Al
Pacino and I'll Pacino yeah he was doing
play with him so back then that was I
was like 1980 or something right yeah
yeah yeah right we look around it was
the first time I saw you was if you
remember at the Albany up there John the
Baptist was the the main event
you know Hells Angel he was a
heavyweight and he was a main event
Kevin Rooney was a cold main event and
none that on the card was Mike Tyson
making his debut Wow so how old 18 18
Mike and we saw this guy was holy
plastic like [ __ ] 10 seconds yeah but uh
we see this saw him that's the first
time we saw him but we came to friends
later that after that because we were
just staying at his John you know for
Kevin fort and yeah and Mike was making
his debut Wow that's 1985 yeah yeah what
six well six look at that yeah you got
to date and that's what happened
so it's unbelievable man so that's how
this whole circle went around like you
said like Mike said Paul Herman
introduced a lot of people yeah and you
guys were just kind of like ships
passing in the night
yeah
yeah it was funny because the first time
I went to cafe central that's what we're
talking about the the bar there we were
watching myself dan Aykroyd and John
blue chill watching the Sugar Ray
Leonard Duran fight the first one at the
Academy music because it was on the
screen 1980 and then well you you got
the dates down by Bob let's got the
dates Louis fighting Sugar Ray Leonard
of the rent yes yes and at the end of
the fight they say come on we're gonna
go to the boys I don't drink I don't
hang out at bars it's all there's a lot
of girls up there and you know
ballerinas and everything I don't go
and I had my Hells Angel patch on and we
walked in there the place was packed I
mean Bruce Willis was the bartender
everybody was there guys like treat
Williams and and Peter Regan and and
John Goodman and Liza Minnelli oh my god
is that so when I walked in with my old
range of jacket on and the Sheila Jaffe
was the host also appalled you my bar no
only thing I remember truthfully is you
were the only guy you were like a freak
you were the only guy who had muscles
you were the only one everybody else
looked like a certain way yeah and then
they saw in become this guy all ripped
up with the tattoos and so we're walking
around this restaurant and this guy Paul
Herman comes up to me the first time
I've met him and he goes could I talk to
you for a minute sure he goes look my
boss just asked me if you could take
your jacket off well I got nerve it was
a great guy I mean awesome me everybody
loves him and I look guys as a pal I
don't think my patro for nobody he goes
well my boss is si well you tell your
boss to come see me it was a p.m. and
Peter Herrera a guy named Peter Herrera
came up because what's the problem I saw
this guy's telling me I gotta take my
jacket he goes well you scaring my
customers you know I'd like you to take
it off I said I'll tell you what I don't
take my patio for nobody and he goes
when you gonna have to leave I said well
I'm gonna leave when
friends leave who I came with John
Belushi and Dan Aykroyd oh my god and
then he goes can I sit down and talk to
you for a minute yeah so we started
talking I said look I'm a Hells Angel
but I got to tell you sir I never drank
in my life I don't never smoked in my
life I don't do drugs nothing and we
started talking at the end of the talk
like a half hour late he goes you know
what you're welcome back anytime you
want after that I was there every
[ __ ] met you there yeah absolutely
absolutely so one I Paulie come well
this is afterwards and then he says all
right great so one night after I'm
staying there me and Paul were in the
back room by the bathrooms at the
restrooms yeah and a guy I was drinking
a coca-cola guy comes out and takes the
kokanee I look at him I said I looked at
him I don't even know this guy from a
whole wall and I say man he goes I'm
thirsty and he had three guys with him I
said you [ __ ] kidding me man you know
so we go outside if it was just him he
brought his friends with him three shots
three knockouts in the middle of the
street and as they all dropped who comes
pulling up in a cop
Peter Herrera he jumps out that's what
I'm talking about that's what I'm
[ __ ] talking about boys beat these
guys started with him I sorry
and after that he offered me a job I
became the bouncer oh [ __ ] yeah
I began the bouncer but now I had the
rule was I had a wear a suit so I
wouldn't wear the jacket so we I thought
but it'll be in the bouncer there and it
was a very exciting time I was great it
was awesome yeah let the China Club a
Broadway I mean we had some good times
scores China Club we did that movie
black-and-white myself and Mike and
everybody else everybody had was in that
yeah and when you think about it so
working firm ended that yeah week we go
back now what's going back and this is
uh now Paul he comes up to me one night
and in and everybody was at Pesci's
there you know just a Raging Bull and
the Nero was hanging out but she knows
everybody was everybody went there you
know that Mike and then he comes up he
goes look he goes a friend of mine just
got mugged down in Hell's Kitchen I says
okay and what happened they teach they
robbed them I saw
and I had my friend Bert number Bert
yeah what the hook yeah I sorry so we
grab the guy was Jimmy Hayden right I am
meaning for the first time yeah and he
goes uh I said what happened he gonna
say he robbed me and he I saw it you
know what we had a van right we had a
couple baseball bats in the van I says
you will go down if you see these guys
just pick them out and we'll take care
of it right so violence so we're going
down with screw a cruising neighborhood
and now he's getting nervous Jimmy now
he's sweating everything else and then
ice what's the matter man he goes look I
got to tell you something you know I
really want Danny to buy drugs and they
robbed me I said what I see you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and uh I went back to
buy support we're ready to take care of
these guys and this guy went to buy
drugs and that's what happened yeah well
that's I met Jimmy Hayden for the first
time and we could became friends he was
a great guy but then of course he died
and like I said me Mickey and Al Pacino
were pallbearers it was back in the day
men the good days the good times Mike ha
ha ha that's crazy
how was it I mean Chuck being a Hells
Angel I mean it's one of the most feared
groups in all of America I mean I've
read hunters hunter as Thompson's but he
wrote that in like days after he got
beaten got beat up
so tell me because he was he was hanging
out with the club for about a year and
they let him you know hang out
everything else and what happened was
one night I was angel having an argument
yeah with his his wife and he smacked
his wife and he and the dog went to hit
bite him with something he kicked the
dog so hunted Thompson goes only Punk's
smack their wives and kicked their dogs
and that's when the guy kicked his [ __ ]
that's Dobson Wow
so and then he went back and he read
that you know wrote that book and I
don't know how long you know some of it
was true someone was [ __ ] but that's
what happened on top sirs man but I was
I was earning for 25 years you know I
had a good time I had some bad times too
I did 6 years you know in prison yeah
but uh I got out but I quit the club 14
years ago
you know been a wild man I can't believe
14 years
mabye so quick make your your motorcycle
rider as well right to the if I do ride
but I ride less and less because
everybody's taxing on you know in it and
when I train I I don't have time to for
a five-month injury to heal because I'm
you know I only had a certain amount of
time left to do my thing and I don't
want to motorcycle injury to chat me
back so it's just like you're you expect
to have injuries riding motorcycle yeah
yeah I'm not the greatest motorcycle
rider you don't my mind floats around
yeah yeah yeah I had a bike a bike
accident but with everybody Texan its
driving is a nightmare
I mean the worst question I ever had I
was only going 10 miles an hour but I
hit oil and uh you know I mean you're
just thinking we need the ground you all
[ __ ] up oh yeah yeah leave it 10 miles
an hour hurt skin off it's that big bike
accident I had that time when I stopped
my leg in half and eight places and road
rash my whole arm was ripped to [ __ ] and
and I always remember Mike always gave
me the shoutout man when I was fighting
again him Orlin Norris yeah you know had
yeah at the end of it and it was awesome
man
it was I just wanted to take a you know
my good friend Chuck Zito get-well-soon
brother I love you peace yeah I love it
well Mike's got a huge heart man
absolutely Chuck [ __ ] that feel quick
Chuck yeah yeah yeah and I was watching
the fight on TV and it just surprised me
man I don't when you're watching it and
the next thing you know because there
was a little controversy there they say
and he hit him at the Bell and this and
that they wanted disqualify him keep his
previous [ __ ] all that man I just want
to look you know I love my friend Chuck
Zito and I remember
man and it's right under there with the
Mike Tyson shadow it says oh yeah
anybody wants to look at it it's awesome
it's awesome man so I love Mike bring
back a long time man yeah Bri training
at 12 yes I was an amateur fighter when
I started at 12 my my first ring fight
at the Southside boys club in the
Rochelle Wow
and then we had that mature fight you
know we will fight different towns
different Club yeah at different times
it was guy named the years ago Bob
kremens you might heard guy and he was
from Pelham so he New Rochelle would
fight Pelham guys and and we just you
know boys clubs and in schools and
things like that so sweet
but I was only an amateur cuz I like I
became a husband a father at 17 so I
couldn't turn pro it makes them good I
have you know I had 40 fights and you
know it's an amateur and well for you
know 36 wins and lost for it's awesome
and I was in the Golden Gloves four
times so it was an experience do they
still do that the boxing clubs yeah yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely slot the
Golden Gloves in New York it's one of
the biggest not as you know what might
that is as much it used to be because
they used to really really uh you know
promoted and everything you hardly hear
about anymore you know now years ago I
had six fights before I even went to the
quarterfinals yeah today they have two
fights to fight for your finals yeah you
know yeah it's amazing guy will have a
fight over the dream when you're golden
car it was it was I was into four times
I never wanted but uh you know I tried
my hardest but again I was like almost
like Mickey and every trained man you
know I just go on it and it actually
trained yeah yeah you know it's odd
between the three of us I mean well Mike
look at him you know
undisputed undisputed heavyweight
champion in the world yes custom ah
because I was cus Mike total discipline
yeah really
what kind of stuff would he have you do
did he just run a super tight ship and
hijae
like psychological mind game Oh what do
you do it's preparing for war
yeah yeah yeah
he had a great teacher Mickey bill
Slaton watch you guys yeah yeah bunch of
guys and of course my father you know
trained me he's always out of my fights
so he's always in my corner what do you
guys think of the state at boxing did
you guys watch the wilder fury fight
what do you think Mick well first of all
I had like three dozen gypsies sitting
next to me and I got a taste of that
world because they were fighting with
all the security guards oh wow okay
minutes later they're fighting with each
other and yeah gypsy the wild okay one
guy screaming his wife you bet you guys
there he's back and forth you thought
about whatever and I'm sitting next to
Axl Rose and some gypsy comes over just
sits on his lap but I had to say get off
his [ __ ] lap you know and the fight
was interesting I I mean you got two
guys six seven six nine whatever people
said to me what do you think I talked to
Freddy who worked a little bit with with
Tyson and Freddy said he liked the way
that that Tyson would switch up because
Tyson's a he's a converted southpaw and
he said what he is most effective punch
was basically what he would switch up
and he throw a straight right jab and a
straight a straight left punch but he
didn't switch up a lot against Wilder
because of Wilders big looping right
hand all right
sometimes he's Wilder would shoot it
straight or hidup it over the top so
it's dangerous for him to turn here
southpaw on okay so you didn't see him
switch up as much as you had prior
fights interesting yeah yes a good
fighter
it's immediate rematch yes cool so
they're gonna fight again
it's awesome I like Tyson you got a
great name and he's had his ups and
downs oh man yeah I mean no doubt what
the the respect what I like is the
respect that both fighters gave each
other I've had the night that's amazing
yeah it wasn't all this this smack talk
it was it was pure genuine respecting
yeah you know at the end of the day you
know what do you think about all the
[ __ ] talking like with counter or Floyd
or I don't I don't have the temperament
to stand there and listen to it yeah
yeah so I would prefer not to say
anything to anybody just remain quiet
but it's really hard when somebody's
three inches away talking so I could
smacking bush that's part of the game
too though yeah yeah part of the game to
get those got a guy through the pen do
the Kannada that's so good yeah yeah I
would lose it you know yeah I get it
that Oh piss me off like the could be
even counter fight I mean fell oh my god
that was something huh I was in for that
for that brawl but I was wrong after
that well that's why I like seeing the
fight with Mike and that big dude from
the street he had a problem with Oh miss
green mid screen mid screen was a dancer
drinking and then I'm seeing us together
yeah talking too much and I couldn't
take up drinking earlier you know you
cannot dance but that was a fine I was
looking forward to seeing yeah yeah yeah
well Mickey what are you up to these
days man we need to give him a key to
toe I'm just looking for a supermodel
baby I'm working with some yeah right
now is the very young director that I
really that I just did a film with and
we want to make a film with integrity
we're not looking to make like action
mindless block poster like me but you're
not moving on that interested I'm not
interested no on that no that's not why
I studied so hard you know for sure the
actor I'm to do that kind of [ __ ]
I don't like buddy that much to to how
to to do that to make that much money I
don't I don't really give a [ __ ] about
money unless I need to pay my bills I
mean there's other things to me that are
more important I mean at the end of the
day you can't take it with you so what
you know yeah it is what it is
you don't go we get together for a
dinner and there's always this other
dude that comes a mistake [ __ ] 80 or
something he's all he talks about is
money and making money and I think what
are you yeah totally whatever various
men told you just teach that it's
nothing it's a blur of energy yeah the
toad shows you that yeah [ __ ] all that
man man is just about spreading love and
being your being your chin your truth
well Chuck thanks for coming in brother
I always a pleasure brother almost
pleasure thanks Mickey bringing me
the house yeah no doubt Mike another
great one man awesome all right awesome
well until next time we're out of here
next time anyone see you when I'm
looking at you you do a picture of me
Chuck and Mike together absolutely
[Music]